I've told you that we're committed to
covering not just the scandals but the
legislative actions of Trump and
Republicans and I have very bad news for
you Donald Trump is responding to the
major student loan crisis that we have
by removing a federal policy preventing
the Department of Education from
charging high fees on past-due student
loans when you default on private
student debt the Department of Education
becomes involved and can sue you garnish
your wages or use your tax refund to
offset your student loan balance Donald
Trump sent a letter to the Department of
Education telling them to get rid of
Obama's rule that barred them from
charging fees for up to 16 percent of
the principal and interest of a loan if
the person in debt signed up for the
program within 60 days of defaulting the
Obama Obama administration set up this
policy when a federal circuit court case
involving a woman being charged forty
five hundred dollars in fees on a loan
she defaulted on in 2012 became sort of
heavily discussed in media The
Washington Post is reporting on this
they say that this move could affect
seven million Americans with a hundred
and sixty two billion dollars in private
student loans Elizabeth Warren and
Suzanne Bonamici senator and
congresswoman respectively sent the
letter to Betsy DeVos at the Education
Department saying please stick with the
Obama administration's policy here
because this is going to be really
really bad for vulnerable borrowers
here's a quote from the letter that they
sent where the senator and congresswoman
said Congress gave borrowers and default
on their federal student loans the
one-time opportunity to rehabilitate
their loans out of default and re-enter
repayment it is inconsistent with the
goal of rehabilitation to return
borrowers to repayment with such large
added fees Rohit Chopra a senior fellow
at the CFA and a former loan specialist
at the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau said quote the administration's
first move on the student loan default
crisis will do nothing to stop the tidal
wave of defaults that is sweeping across
the nation with more than three thousand
americans defaulting on a student loan
every day this adds in
to injury this is not going to be good
for the economy this is coming from
Trump the king of debt and not paying
people by the way the cost of higher
education is a matter here that should
be looked at the way in which students
loans student loans [ __ ] borrowers is
a major issue issue and the right likes
to blame the borrowers plain and simple
and say hey it's their problem
don't take out the loans or get a job
that pays more but of course we have
this vicious circle we've talked about
Pat where tuition increases lead to
bigger loans and loosening of
restrictions lead to more predatory
lending and you have a middle class wage
a stagnation that has lasted decades
you've got middle class individuals not
making more money than they did 30 years
ago in inflation adjusted dollars but
tuition has increased exponentially what
do you think is going to happen now
you're just going to punish the
borrowers when you've not delivered an
economy that sees a middle-class wage
increase this is blaming the victims and
that's why it's important to have a
Secretary of Education who has a deep
understanding of student loans either in
a personal setting or a professional
setting but of course we know Betsy
DeVos comes from a lot of privileged who
have qualified for this role and this is
the result this is completely
unsurprising and yet another way in
which Trump said he'd be good for the
average person and this is terrible for
the average person